there's no time o clock all right we're
back this episode's gonna be another one
of true crime episodes because you guys
request that one let you guys request to
crime like crazy that's what I mean I'm
sure you guys miss that recurrent but
you know yeah we got we do other stuff
too everybody likes different things we
likes different things yeah yeah the
show we did last week about ujin Sando
usually sand down a lot of the other
guys that started off bodybuilding you
know actually is getting a little bit
more popular than I thought it would be
you know people that was there the
comments in the section like I probably
wouldn't have listened to a show like
this before but as you guys I listened
to it was [ __ ] hilarious
it is a hilarious show if you guys want
to go back and check it out I may not
sound real exciting you know I mean to a
person who doesn't know anything about
it but there's a lot of interesting
characters back in the [ __ ] late
1800s Early 1900s started that whole
thing and that's that's really where the
idea of the show came from was like
strong men and mostly like guys like
Eugene Sandow you know and [ __ ] how
how much they changed things and what
kind of [ __ ] big characters they were
in terms of the [ __ ] the weird [ __ ]
that they did and you know [ __ ]
trying to people were trying to get
male-enhancement by so and [ __ ] goat
nuts into their [ __ ] testicles and
[ __ ] so they'd have three balls it's
[ __ ] all kinds of crazy [ __ ] people
try to do I don't even know if they have
tried to have three balls I think they
were like replacing their balls with
yeah basically it was like an attempt at
TRT was an attempt at testosterone
placement therapy which i don't know how
desperate you'd have to be to do that
they did some stupid [ __ ] back then so I
mean people do stupid [ __ ] now but it's
like I think it's nothing compared to
like what old timey people you go back
and read the comments on that show
you'll see people saying man I never
would have watched a show like this if
it wasn't for you guys [ __ ] shows all
areas it's a hilarious show you guys it
was a more interesting topic than I was
dissipating actually yeah it's like you
know there well guys with big egos do
hilarious [ __ ] and you know not point
people in the right direction where they
go [ __ ] either do hilarious [ __ ] or
terrible [ __ ] yeah
Shanina we're talking about a much less
awesome individual yeah it's very funny
because this was this has been requested
a couple of times a long time ago and I
think I kind of hinted around that like
what the what the topic was gonna be
like on one of the side track shows I
think it was like Thursdays and I said
it's a German serial killer and it was
like a long time ago like it was like
the beginning of the 20th century or
something and I thought it was funny
because somebody and the YouTube
comments tried to guess and they guessed
like a whole bunch and none of them were
the right one and because that was
something that I wanted to discuss I'm
not really sure okay so I'm gonna start
this whole thing I've you know I'm gonna
do shoutouts and everything - but here's
like a little preamble what the [ __ ]
Germany because in the time period in
between roughly in between the first and
second world war
y'all had an alarming number of serial
killers running around and like [ __ ]
up ones too like cannibals and all this
kind of [ __ ] and I I don't think anyone
is entirely sure why that is I don't
know if it's because there were actually
more of them running around or if it was
just because Germany at the time they
kept better records or the cops were
better and they caught them you know so
they identified them and stuff like that
but I'm not really sure why that should
be but there are a really a lot of them
we've talked about one of them on the
show before I think back on our Vampire
Killers show Fritz Hartmann what time
period did you say again between the
first and second world war but there
abouts okay but yeah there were like a
whole bunch of different ones I thought
it was very funny that like that the
person in the youtube comment was like
guessing a bunch of different ones that
I'm like all good guesses but no we are
actually today talking about Peter
Kurten the vampire of Dusseldorf I don't
think I've ever heard this guy which is
amazing because wow wow what here we're
talking about what a horrible horrible
person very early 20th century
from like right around his his kind of
heyday was like 1929 1930 yeah yeah well
you had some weird [ __ ] like that go on
going on through in the United States -
I mean you had [ __ ] guy who built his
own murder hotel and which home
agh homes you had them it's just I don't
know maybe it's me some kind of phase
that [ __ ] societies go through like a
cycle it could be because I do feel like
and we've mentioned this on the show
before but it's like you know I wrote
about a lot of crimes that happened in
the early part of the 20th century and a
lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] happen back then
remembered like because remember I was
saying how there was just this big rash
of like axe murders yeah like all over
the place they weren't like related or
anything I don't know if it was just
because axes like everybody had one so
it was kind of like a weapon of
convenience type of [ __ ] remember that
remember that point yes i statistical
yeah you remember that one time we were
we were talking about in Canada there's
a place with like there's yeah cities
next week London Ontario
yeah London Ontario it had something to
do with the construction of some
highways yeah in fact the economy went
bad miss and the city started to
stagnate and and a bunch of them there
was like an outbreak there yeah I think
it has to do with like a lot of things
that wants easy transportation yeah it's
not a perfect storm of factors yeah like
a easy you have a free society with easy
transportation and a a well-built city
scape but it's undergoing contraction
like you know I mean like there's an
economic decline yeah which you know
it's kind of like parasites coming out
and feeding on it or or maggots coming
out of the woodwork to feed on a damn
dead body or something yeah you know I
mean there's a lot of cityscape there
and a lot of little nooks and crannies
and a lot of people that love the good
people are leave and leaving behind kind
of like you know a rougher type people
or people that don't have the ability to
move so they all start cannibalizing one
another in a way yeah you know maybe I
thought that was the idea I had back
then then I I think that was probably
the thing behind
in Ontario I think the thing about that
was that it was kind of like a large
city that had largely been kind of like
cut off from other cities around it but
then like all these new highways started
to get built through it and there was
like all these new um you know people
coming through like more transient yeah
population which usually amounts to more
serial killers which is why there were
so many in California like in the 60s
and 70s because you get this big influx
of people you know moving there and with
the big influx of people comes people
preying on that video it looks like a
challenge yeah which i think is fair
yeah which happened in Chicago right
the thing about maybe that was happening
in Germany I don't know I feel like
maybe I feel like maybe it was a kind of
thing because there was a lot of poverty
there was a lot of social unrest there
was a lot of that but there was a lot of
that going on in other parts of Europe
and in parts of the US as well and you
didn't see this spike I suspect and I'm
not the only person that suspects
there's other crime writers that have
that have kind of theorized this as well
is that maybe it's just because the
German police for the authorities and
stuff like that were actually better
organized and had better kind of like
forensic techniques and stuff like that
could catch these guys more and you
heard about them more because the thing
about it is that Peter Kurten in
particular a psychologist named dr. Karl
Berg he wrote a book about this guy he
was actually the pathologist that did
like the autopsies on most of his
victims so he was like right there it
threw the whole case he knew all about
it and he interviewed the guy like
extensively before he was executed and
he wrote a book called the sadist and it
came out in the 30s it's you know it's
in the public domain you can Bree I have
the PDF like I haven't I didn't have
time to read the whole thing but I like
you know kind of skimmed through parts
of it and everything
like trying to just get the thing and it
is amazingly modern like in its
breakdown of why this dude why was the
way he was you know another thing that
could it could be is that if he's a
German serial killer in Germany he's
gonna be contained inside Germany if you
have a serial killer in the United
States there's a bunch of states and
they all speak English he kills in one
state he can move
on 12 I was on a train that hops on
train now he's in another sister in ever
catching yeah so it's easier to catch
him if he's contained inside Germany
that's true so not only is it a better
police for just more effective because
they don't have to [ __ ] cooperate
they don't have to communicate and
cooperate with people outside of Germany
to catch a dude I think that really did
stymie a lot of stuff and early in the
you know in the United States history is
that all you had to do and we've
mentioned this before as well all you
had to do was like pop over to another
state change your name you're free and
no one would be the wiser yeah the
United States is because it's a bunch of
states that got United they really are
independent they really were independent
countries and particularly back then is
even more so yeah and they didn't have
like any way of communicating with one
another or like you can mashing up yeah
it was like motorized bandits like
Bonnie and Clyde would commit a [ __ ]
heinous robbery and kill cops right near
the [ __ ] border online between two
states and just drive across the border
and the other cops would just stop and
watch them go couldn't do anything yeah
and then cops on the other side of the
border couldn't even do anything
couldn't charge them or arrest them
because that that crime wasn't clear
state wasn't in their jurisdiction yep
so they eventually got rid of that that
around that time yeah because you see
how that would be like a really bad
thing to have yeah the feds made the
feds made an interstate compact between
all the states that the states had the
right to each state had a right to
arrest you for a crime committed in
another state and also [ __ ] to like now
you have the FBI where if you take a
crime over state lines then the FBI it
becomes involved if it's a bad enough
it's a murder yeah and you're better
than the state police right so so that's
kind of what happened but yeah so I kind
of want to get all kind of like go into
some of the other like serial killers
just very briefly and then we'll talk
about Peter Kurten because this guy and
it's weird because he's not one that
comes up a lot with like when you talk
about like really horrible serial
killers but he is for real like just
straight up evil he had like the very
very similar thing because remember when
we did the show about carl panzram yeah
who was just kind of like his whole
thing was just revenge and he just hated
everybody yeah man he's a rapist yeah
raping man this just meant
this guy was similar even but he was
like less it he was very sexually
motivated he was a lust killer he was
you know women and little girls mainly
he did kill men also so he was kind of
indiscriminate and even though I think
his primary motivation was sexual and he
admitted as much he did actually have a
big thing where he was taking revenge
against society because of the way that
he had grown up and the way that he had
been treated like in cars and he was to
be fair he was horribly horribly abused
when he was a child not excusing the
dude but just made a monster yeah it he
definitely did turn out a monstrous
individual with who admitted openly that
he had no conscience no pity no remorse
about anything he was just like kind of
that's how he got his jollies you know
what I mean just by doing this like
[ __ ] up sadistic [ __ ] but yeah I
recommend the book the sadist like I
said by dr. Karl Berg you can find it
online it's free you can download it
from archive.org I think that's where I
got it like a PDF of the original and
like I said it's it's it's a very modern
look into like a serial killer it's it
could have been written you know just a
couple years ago which I was kind of
amazed about so let's just do a couple
of brief shout outs before we kind of
get into it I wanted to thank again Neil
a hopefully I'm pronouncing that right
like I said he never corrects me so I
guess I'm pronouncing it sort of right
who gave us a PayPal donation I thanked
him on the side track show but like I
said I was like to save the main [ __ ]
for the show I don't remember if we
thanked Rob on the main show for sending
us sexy beast
but you haven't thank you again yeah we
should still you have to watch it yes I
still gonna watch that I'm like I said
it's an awesome movie like I've seen it
before I saw it in the theater also I
just wanted this on the side track show
but in case you guys don't listen to
those that I was going to I'm we're not
gonna stop doing this on track show
we're still gonna put content up every
single day but what I decided I might do
particularly with the matinee show was I
just thought it was kind of pointless
now that we don't do the a-list thing
anymore we go to the theatre and all
that other kind of stuff I thought it
was pointless to just like lump all the
three new movie reviews together on one
show and so I decided to just
like break them up like during the week
so we're gonna put up like three matinee
shows like doing with just one movie
like we talked about one movie we or we
might do three with my two-for-one 92 we
might do whatever but then if there's a
day when we don't have anything going up
like a movie review then we'll do a
sidetracks so so we'll always have
something going up it just might not
necessarily be a sidetracks it might be
a matinee it might be an old movie
review or something else it'll be
something else so I just wanna that's
kind of the goal as I won't have like
one thing going up everything the
sidetrack show was really just a
temporary thing anyway that was for the
pandemic and now that that's kind of
getting that's winding down we're just
gonna we're just gonna kinda like I said
we'll keep it but we're just gonna make
sure that one thing goes up every day
yeah the side mag is different each day
but the sidetracks will probably be just
to fill in fill in Dead days if we don't
have something if we don't have a movie
review for that day or if we don't have
something else going out for that
everything else is gonna stay the same
the movie retrospective is still gonna
go up on Friday witching hour so gonna
go about Thursday the regular stuff is
still gonna go up on Tuesday but all the
other days we're gonna either put a
matinee or a sidetrack you all new all
new movies but there won't be a matinee
really all new movies will be reviewed
separately yeah and it'll still be
called Matt name yet it'll just be one
more instead of three right you know
Scooby Rhett was to do retrospective
yeah we'll do at least one retrospective
like I said if we watch more than one
like old movie a week and we'd feel like
we're viewing that too I might put two
up a week we just don't have but
something will go up every day so don't
be alarmed or not getting rid of
anything really we're just kind of like
you're trying to streamline stuff
streamline it so we always have
something to talk about like on the show
so now as I was saying there really were
a lot of like kind of heavy hitter
serial killers operating in Germany
between roughly between World War 1 and
World War 2
you had Karl Benke known as Papa dinky
the serial killer Papa dinky oh good he
was actually a cannibal also he actually
went after homeless people and people
that were traveling he's called The
Forgotten cannibal
I don't know how you could forget
somebody like that but okay others have
good press estas there was also a Karl
Grossman also a cannibal he actually
they don't know a lot about I mean they
know he committed a [ __ ] set of crimes
in like eight people but they don't know
how like exactly what the all the
details have at work as he killed
himself before he could be brought to
trial then you got dole Fritz Harmon who
like I said he we talked about him I
think on our Vampire Killers show
because he's called the vampire pan over
the butcher of Hanover
he killed at least 24 boys and young men
murder mutilation and dismemberment then
you have a johan mayor who a one-armed
serial killer maybe the only woman I
never heard of any other one they called
him a stoop farm like stump arm you know
me I warned that we're lost a harm I'm
not sure actually stomp I think he was
born that way I born that way yeah but
yeah so like I said if you know of any
other one-armed serial killers he's a
one-armed serial killer he actually
killed five people I believe then there
was Friedrich Schumann known as the
terror of Falken hagen lake he murdered
seven people and rapes eleven women and
was executed in 1921 then you had Paul
or Gore's o or or GERD or Zhou I don't
know he was a serial killer and rapist
known as the s-bahn murderer he killed
eight women in nazi area berlin between
october 1940 and July 1941 so you know
and that's even before we get to Peter
Kurten so there's and there's more of
them than that those are just kind of
like the main ones that kind of get
talked about I should say too that Peter
Kurten and I believe Fritz Hartmann were
the kind of dual inspirations for the
very famous classic horror movie Fritz
Lang's M about the child killer so which
you know with Peter Lorre you see it
you've never seen it no oh it's good
it came out the 30s yeah you see it yeah
oh it's good but that's but this is who
it's based on like loosely based on its
it's kind of like a fictionalized child
killer that's kind of based on Peter
Kurten and a couple other serial killers
so all right so let's talk about this
[ __ ] douche bag so it's like Peter
Kurten the you has a umlaut because he's
metal no he's really not that old like
he's not cool at all he's so as I said
he's called the vampire of Dusseldorf or
the Dusseldorf Monster committed a
series of murders and sexual assaults
between February and November 1929
although there were some before that and
like this dude did everything murders
rapes arson burglary just [ __ ] he was
incorrigible he would just go around
like stabbing people I could [ __ ]
random like in the strand stuff he was
just like a how old was he when he
started all this you go tell us well he
started when he when he first started
killing according to him nine okay first
murders were when he was nine or so he
claimed I mean the the kids were dead
it's just you know they it was ruled an
accent but I'll get into that so you
know like I said he also had like oh
[ __ ] ton of attempted murders as well he
was ultimately convicted of I think
seven murders either seven murders and
nine murders I can't remember a whole
bunch of attempted murders even though
he probably did like a [ __ ] ton more
than that because he confessed like as
soon as they like got him in custody
because he knew he was caught so he was
born in mole hi mom Rhine which i think
is near cologne and he was born in 1883
now he was the oldest of 13 children and
his family lived in a one-bedroom
apartment jam 13 of them in one room
yeah yeah that's bound [ __ ] yeah it will
just wait yeah now apparently the the
parents had had two kids before him but
I guess they both died like really young
um so I don't know if it's 13 total
total or if it's 13 including those two
you know what I mean it's not
Claire about that so the family was
super super poor mostly because the dad
was a drunk um he had a job he was he
worked in a like a molder like they made
moldings or whatever but he spent almost
all of his money on booze yeah and he
was also violently abusive and liked to
rape the mom in front of the other kids
like he would gather all the kids and
rape their mom and make the kids watch
dan also later on went into raping the
sisters Dan
so you know so he's already coming out
of a [ __ ] piss poor environment yeah
it was really really not good
yeah so um it weirdly it seems like the
UM the dad actually did get arrested for
incest right for having sex with one of
the daughters who was 13 at the time
yeah she brought went to the cow yeah
I'm sure I think well actually I think
what ended up happening was that the
cops came to the house because they were
investigating one of Peters you know
burglaries or whatever yeah and while
they were there either something like
somebody told the police hey he's doing
like raping the daughter or whatever so
they arrested the dad so I think he only
got maybe a little over a year in prison
for that right though but you know um I
think unusually for the time because I
just feel like that's unusual for the
time because I feel like just a lot of
people just get away with it yeah you
know what I mean probably did back then
yeah like beating up your wife and kids
raping your kids I just feel like people
are like a they were like well that's
between those people that's yeah I feel
like that's what happens well that's
what happens and those poor people over
there you know and so I feel like they
don't do anything so after that happened
like after he went to jail for incest
with the daughter
Peter curtains mom actually got a
divorce if you know luckily to her and
she actually remarried and moved to
Dusseldorf now as if this home situation
wasn't horrifying enough after they
moved to Dusseldorf there was the
building that they lived in and this was
when
Peter was about nine years old there was
this other guy who was like in his 40s I
think and he lived in the same building
and he was a dog catcher and him and
Peter started hanging out even though
this guy was in his 40s and Peter was
nine now the dog catcher showed this
little kid how to like jerk off dogs and
how to torture animals and got him into
bestiality okay Dan um so Peter was like
nice yeah so already like I said already
this kid is messed up right now
yeah so yeah so they were like really
close friends and hung out together and
like went around torturing dogs and
raping dogs and jerking off and all this
other kind of stuff so you know just
regular kid stuff that's why he became a
dog catcher well yeah exactly yeah and
then of course you know you know who's
we got we got old what's-his-name our
favorite dog catcher right back there
she did that right well you know just
because just because he's a dog catcher
that doesn't that doesn't mean any time
he's not you know
BTK was in a dog catcher he was a he
started off as a dog catcher right thing
he did was he a dog catcher for a while
um I don't think he was exactly he was
like a code enforcement person so I
think it included like if there were
straight dogs and stuff we have to take
him to the pound or whatever yeah cuz he
was even hassling that one victim yeah
the dog and [ __ ] yes I thought he was
also not only code enforcement I thought
it involved [ __ ] catching people's
dogs too yeah I think it like it kind of
oh he called a dog catcher and they did
it yeah I think it all fell under the
same umbrella because I think he did
actually have to like take dogs in the
amount of ad caster yeah because because
he was um I remember reading like in the
book that Sophie sent me that he seemed
kind of like upset that people were
calling him a dog catcher because that
wasn't exactly what it was I mean it was
part of his job but it wasn't as a whole
job now right around the same time that
Peter Kurten is hanging around with this
[ __ ] up older dude this dog catcher
person he also later
said that him and two of his little
friends I guess they weren't his friends
but two other little boys that were
about his age they were out um on a on
the Rhine River like in a raft or
something like going raft and like
little kids do and apparently Peter
decided he was gonna push one of them
into the river to see what would happen
so he pushed one of them into the river
the other kid was like hey bro what are
you up to and he jumped in to save the
other kid at which point Peter leans
over the raft and holds them both under
the water rounds them drowns of Botha
yep [ __ ] now this was actually later
said that it was found to be accidental
because you know I guess he just came
back and said hey they fell in a drowned
there was nothing I can do about it
and I think that he said something to
the effect was this was one of the first
times that he realized that he could
basically just do whatever he wanted to
yeah and and just lie about it and
people would buy it you know what I mean
and that like made him feel like really
powerful and stuff so he drowned these
two [ __ ] kids when he was 9 years old
so that damn now another thing that
started to happen around this time right
around the time that he was going
through puberty like I said this
doggcatcher guy had like introduced him
to the joys of beast yeah so he was
getting into that homosexual bestiality
too oh he's having sex with the male
dogs isn't that what you're implying
yeah I guess so well I don't know if it
was it was just whatever dog they found
a male or if it was a male they would
just like grab the red rocket and I
don't know I just heard it somewhere
like it several times I was like okay
that's called I don't know I didn't look
it up or anything so so he graduates
from from dogs and then he starts um you
know performing bestiality on like sheep
and goats
get nearby stables and I guess he got
into a thing where he could only really
like the orgasm was heightened if he
stabbed the Sheep while he was [ __ ]
it damn like because he had like a weird
sexual thing and this seemed to have
like just popped out like fully
developed when he was going through
puberty to like blood gushing like he
was really into that like he's so he was
into like having sex with a victim
raping a victim or an animal or whatever
while it's blood was was gurgling out
that was like a really like a really
erotic charge for him like sometimes he
would just go back to a scene later
where he had done something and just
thinking about it would make him like
blah blah you know what I mean it's
funny you think of sheep it [ __ ]
[ __ ] kill him for doing them and
they're pretty strong well maybe that's
how he discovered it maybe he was like
having his way with one and that sheep
decided they didn't [ __ ] like it and
started like fighting him and so he
stabbed it
well no I'm talking about stabbing it
would make anyone worse she would think
it in rage cheap at pride kill you I
don't know I guess nothing they didn't
want at once makes you wonder if he kind
of made that up like maybe he was having
sex with a sheep but maybe makes me
doubt that he was stabbing him while I
was doing it and that he could get away
with that because you would think an
animal would instinctively fight back
yeah and you know I don't know how big
he was at that time he was going through
puberty but how big was he I mean I'm
thinking this was like around when he
was 12 or 13 years old because a sheep
man [ __ ] enraged sheep fighting for
his life guy I think would kill maybe
okay maybe he like picked on little ones
yeah I don't yeah maybe you know maybe
like little lambs yeah but even they
would fight back pretty hard you know I
mean they have foods I mean a 20 pound
Bobcat can [ __ ] kill you yeah yeah uh
but like but then again is cheap in the
back yeah but you know I never
underestimated you know there's a
strength of an animal
well the asier has put me in the bucket
hahahahahaha she's just bite me [ __ ] the
hospital for like a week nothing like
God [ __ ] that infection from that
[ __ ] cowboy rat fever
it wasn't coming it was
like yeah it was like a staff of some
sort from her little yes she didn't mean
to fight no it's just like an accident
well a little bitty teeth they're like
hypodermic needles soon and the holes
close up and then they gets infected in
there you know what I mean and then I
thought it'd be alright and then like
two or three days later I was like this
isn't going good yeah like swelled way
yeah like this isn't going see the blood
yeah yeah yeah damn Hospital yeah I
forgot what it was called they had a
name for the type of infection that it
was yeah it wasn't as cat scratch fever
that's toxoplasmosis yeah that's that
was just the first thing I thought of
yeah no no okay I don't have taxes place
mostly just [ __ ] worms in your brain
yeah so again surprisingly not
surprisingly when Peter Kurten was a
teenager his dad beat the crap out of
him as well um he was actually did
pretty good in school but because of his
home life he couldn't really concentrate
or anything and he kept like running
away from home um and he kind of like
when he ran away from home he would like
start hanging around with like a bunch
of other like criminals and [ __ ] you
know stealing sentient [ __ ] on fire you
know [ __ ] like that like little kids do
so that's kind of how he you know made
enough money to like stay out on the
streets or like stay away from home for
like extended periods of time just by
stealing [ __ ] now when he was 13 years
old um he found I don't want to call her
a girlfriend but he found this girl who
would let him like take her clothes off
and like feel her up and stuff but
wouldn't let him have sex with her I
mean they're 13 so you know that's kind
of the way that [ __ ] goes so you know he
started going back to the like the Sheep
and the pigs and the goats and
everything like that
and then he targeted the same sister
that his father had been raping right
who was 13 or 14 years old at the time
so that's nice because I guess he was
like frustrated by this girl like not
letting him
what'd she do with her what did you do
the sister what the sister do about what
oh she just let it happen well I don't
know she's a little kid you know what I
mean okay well dark teens big enough to
[ __ ] fight baggie she didn't tell
anybody
well obviously they told somebody
because dad went to jail for it yeah you
think okay I'm just saying you know so
1897 Peter leaves school now his dad got
him an apprenticeship at the moulding
factory like that he worked at Curtin
actually worked there for about two
years
and then he decided [ __ ] this [ __ ] he
stole a bunch of money from his employer
about three hundred marks and he stole
some money from his own house and took
off he went to this town called Koblenz
and here he hooked up with a prostitute
he was only I think two years older than
him he was like a little bit older
teenager at this time and he and she
would let him like do whatever he wanted
to her like other than murdering her
obviously but he would like she would
let him do like all kind of violent [ __ ]
and everything and I guess like she
allowed it so that went on for about a
month and then he got arrested for
breaking and entering and theft and went
to prison for only a month so he gets
out in August of 1899 and goes back on
the streets and starts committing crimes
and [ __ ] like that
now the first official murder that he
said to commit it was I mean if he is to
be believed the first murder the city
committed for those two little boys that
he drowned but since that was ruled
accidental and they you know couldn't go
back and do it because it was many years
later this is considered his first
official murder this was November of
1899 he said that he picked up an
eighteen-year-old girl and asked her to
come back with him to the Hoffman the
HOF Garten whatever and he had sex with
her I don't know if it was consensual or
not
or if it was rape and then he strangled
her to death with his bare hands
now because they never found a body in
this case they are assuming that either
he made it up although there's really no
reason for him to have made it up
because he did much worse [ __ ] later on
or they speculate that this woman
actually survived like that he was
actually left her for dead
yeah but she came back and then after he
took off she like crawled away and never
reported it because they never could
find her but that McCourty to him that
was the first she live he committed so
that's what most people think that she
probably lived and took off and was like
[ __ ] this I'm not and then dude like
just never reported it so um he so he
said that around this time that he
committed this murder
that was when he realized that the only
way that he could achieve this kind of
like really heightened orgasm or
whatever like this bliss that he wanted
to achieve was by murdering someone
through violence you know what I mean so
that was kind of when that solidified
for him I suppose so a little while
after that he gets arrested for fraud
that was in 1900 he gets he spends a
couple months in jail he gets out and
then he gets arrested again the same
year for the same thing um so you know
like I said he's just doing all this
petty crime which it's kind of common
with serial killers they do these kind
of like burglaries thefts and [ __ ] like
that he was kind of like cuz I guess he
didn't have a job at this point so
that's kind of how he was surviving just
by like stealing [ __ ] you know doing
that kind of crap um he also there was
also around this time he was arrested
for attempted murder for attempting to
shoot a woman with a shotgun I believe
it was but she lived so he got four
years for that now he gets out in the
summer of 1904 and gets drafted into the
German army now he goes to
Metz and was going to serve in the 98th
Infantry Regiment
although
he was a very um he was one of those I
hate Authority people you know what I
mean like carp very much like carl
panzram same kind of like thing where he
he like hated everybody and he didn't
want anybody telling him what to do so
he deserted like he you know he wasn't
there very long and he's like [ __ ]
took off later that same year he got
into arson one of the things he really
liked to do was he would go around and
like set barns and houses and [ __ ] on
fire because and then like he would come
back later like when the firefighters
were there putting out the fire and
everyone was there like freaking out
it's like oh my house or whatever
because he got off on the chaos that he
had caused and watching people like cry
about like losing their property and I
was like he'd like that really like got
his yeah he got his jollies from like
watching people's suffering yeah yeah so
that's why they called the book to say
this because he just he really seemed to
enjoy other people's misery he didn't
have anything so anybody else to have
anything it does it really does seem
like he had that kind of I mean you know
like I said he did have a really
horrible shitty childhood like I said
that's not excusing anything but you can
see where his mindset came from because
he thought well everyone has treated me
shitty so I'm just gonna treat every
gonna treat the world shitty right back
because the world has crapped on me yeah
so I will crap on it in return which
like I said very carl panzram same kind
of [ __ ] yeah
so it's funny how they go after the
innocent ones though that I know and the
weird thing about him is that I mean
according to his dad yeah I did go on
after my dad yeah it's like I wanna like
rub out the people that like actually
like cause you're suffering really like
more than just a random person I mean
what the [ __ ] do they have to do with
anything
yeah but the weird thing about him is
that from what I read because there was
like you know he he talked to dr. Carl
Burke who were at the book like a lot
and there's like a lot of like you know
it you know interviews with him and
stuff like that and the strange thing
about him is he's he's really really
intelligent and he really does seem to
have a very um he's very insightful
about why he does what he does he
understands that he's attacking innocent
people
that didn't have anything to do with
what happened to him he understands that
yeah
but he's saying that he's like well yeah
one he didn't care and two he had this
weird thing like where it's almost kind
of like well if the universe allowed its
happen or if God allowed it to happen
then God will understand like why I did
it and like it'll like work itself out
kind of thing like he had that kind of
like I'm balancing the scales or
something so he almost had even though
like I said he's primarily like a lust
style killer he also had a little bit of
like mission style killer where he felt
like he was revenge
in Justices and you know even if it's
innocent people well nobody's innocent
you know what I mean it just all works
out on this so he really had that kind
of thing so he committed about 24 acts
of arson
mostly barns and stuff like you know um
and he also he also said too that not
only did he get off on watching the [ __ ]
burn and watching people freaking out
about it burning
but he also fantasized about there being
homeless people sleeping in there and
that they were burning alive why almost
once well just people because they were
the ones that would be sleeping in a
barn okay he you know so he had a thing
where he had sexual fantasies about
killing large numbers of people at one
time like either burning a whole house
full of people alive or um like running
a train off a track or something like
that like he really got off on thinking
about killing a whole bunch of people at
once well this kind of look like big guy
little guy um he was pretty well-built
dude the weird thing about him is that
he was actually not a bad-looking guy
for the time yeah and he always looked
real dapper Oh kind of like HH Holmes
like he always had a real nice suit he
always had like his hair was always
parted and combed and yeah had his
little pomade in there and everything
like that
yeah so yeah so he looked pretty slick
um
and I think that's kind of why cuz he
was very um narcissistic right and he
was like real vain about like his
personal appearance like so he wasn't
like a dirty hobo or nothing like that
like he really did look like a like a
respectable dude
so um because he had deserted from the
army he got tried and convicted
desertion and got a whole bunch of other
counts of arson robbery attempted
robbery blah-dee-blah and he went to
prison from 1905 to 1913 the onion how
did you get caught monster I'm not
really sure officially they just they
just caught him that's walking on
streams like a you're that guy probably
there are too many scenes of the crime
because you know no no it is is like
they've always known or at least they've
known in modern times that a serial
arsonist will be there in the crowd
watch yeah yep and you know they tell
firemen to you know keep track of who's
there for the weirdo that little too
happy yeah and if you're spotted more
than once and at fires you're gonna be a
[ __ ] suspect yeah so rightly so so
maybe he just kept appearing it to be
kept well in there like that
[ __ ] doing it that's not um
that's probably not too far out of the
bounds of possibility because there are
there were some cases where he turned up
at the scenes of his murders like to
watch people like reacting to it yeah
like the next day and stuff so that was
his downfall I'm showing a bit um that's
actually not how he got caught but um
yeah but that's probably how he got
caught for the arson though sounds what
I would imagine because he did like to
go back and like watch everybody run it
around I bet you German firemen knew
about arsonists serial arsonists maybe
so maybe they knew that they kept coming
back yeah
the to the biggest to the biggest [ __ ]
you know when it comes to serial arson
an arsonist a lot of times they you know
one of the main groups of suspects are
[ __ ] firemen yeah did you know that
yeah serial arsonist become fireman
quite a bit at least they used to well
it's just kind of like you know you want
to be another fire risk pedophiles
becoming priests or childcare workers
it's like anything like that if you're
if you're like so in
to commit a particular type of crime
sometimes you want to pursue a career
that's gonna get you as close as
possible to the [ __ ] and even back in
Rome professional firefighters would
they all had their own little companies
they would be in competition with one
another and if there weren't enough
fires happen and they go out and set a
fire to make money yeah people don't
think of that well yeah see that's it
that's why it's good that we don't have
a for-profit fire service yeah anymore
because they would develop that virus
they're like man we're like we're out of
money we gotta go [ __ ] a set of fire we
had not a fire in like six weeks man
what is this and then they show up and
then go they see your house burn it and
then they're gone okay how much you
don't pay us for sure that completely
burned yet ground no no no Fire Company
would show up and the two [ __ ] fire
compass would get in a [ __ ] war of
bidding war I mean why is trying to get
yet to get there is this house yeah oh
well yeah well they had loan agents with
them yeah you know I mean to [ __ ]
loan you the money yeah put the fire out
so the loan sharks to get you ass that
figures something else huh yeah just
yeah maybe you don't want for profit I
mean why come find me as things are now
it's like I just think back well it was
a lot worse back then back then you just
had to [ __ ] pay yeah your house
burning down on purpose yeah probably
it's like the [ __ ] mob yeah like
better not to have a fire department
yeah I have a fire department because
the [ __ ] that does that yeah well yeah
it was better not like everybody else
put out my own fire except those fire
departments down we'll put them out it's
a buckets get a hose everybody's gotta
have a bucket so fire you can run down
and [ __ ] you know Phil you buck it up
but yeah so he gets put in prison now
like I said he has a problem with
authority but also he likes being in
solitary confinement so he would on
purpose like do insubordination and
stuff like that so he would get thrown
in solitary because
when he got thrown in solitary he had
all this peace and privacy yeah - like
construct his elaborate sexual fantasies
about killing everybody in the world
like by burning everyone up and all this
other kind of stuff and like you know
jerk off but he didn't have to jerk off
about it he said that just thinking
about it just made him spurt off him
without even touching the [ __ ] yeah he
could just spread it off that's what he
said
so he was like super into this [ __ ] hey
guys I mean sounds like kind of like the
[ __ ] The Joker
yes yeah he is he is an agent of chaos
big time so here is um hit one of his
first here's his first like official
murder cuz like I said he thought the
murder was like the 18 year old that he
had strangled and stuff but they never
found her so they're assuming that she
lived but his first official official
murder was a nine-year-old girl named
Christine Klein now what he had taken to
doing cuz like I said he was also a
burglar and he had started specializing
in like public bars or like ins like
taverns and stuff that had like you know
lodging upstairs so this is what he said
this is a quote from from him direct
from his mouth he says it was 25th of
May 1913 in a room above an inn at coal
mill Heim I discovered a child of about
10 asleep and this was Christine Klein
her head was facing the window I seized
it with my left hand and strangled her
for about a minute and a half
the child woke up and struggled but lost
consciousness
I had a small but sharp pocketknife with
me and I held the child's head and cut
her throat
I heard the blood spurt and drip on the
mat beside the bed it spurted in an arch
right over my hand
the whole thing lasted about three
minutes then I locked the door again and
went back home to Dusseldorf like he was
like looking around apparently in this
in for stuff to steal and he couldn't
find anything and then he just
open the store I was like how fortuitous
a nine-year-old girl did I am I'm just
gonna like cut her [ __ ] through now
the creepy thing is that he didn't rape
her rape her but they think that he like
this is cerberus they think that he like
jerked off on his fingers like he came
on his fingers and like stuck his
fingers in her vagina because they did
find like semen in there but not you
know to an extent and she and he
probably did it like really roughly to
because they did find like bruising and
[ __ ] and this is from like I said this
is from dr. Karl Berg who did all the
autopsies and he did the autopsy on this
girl though um he did yeah okay he
didn't admit to molesting the dead body
um I'm not sure if he admitted to it or
not like he admitted to pretty much
everything so I would imagine so I'm
just saying I knew that because I read
it in that's what the UM the coroner
said look in the book what this is
verified they found the body they know
the homicide he's Tommy yeah she he was
she was just in bed okay
okay and the shitty thing about this is
that what had it up happening was that
so this was just like a random crime
nobody had seen him like come into the
place cuz he broke into the end went
dead the dad guy the uncle did because
this is what happened the dad was named
Peter Klein okay so they find a
hankerchief and it was belonged to Peter
Kurten at the scene and it had his
initials on it PK well the dad's
initials were also PK now the dad had a
brother named Otto who was Christine's
uncle now
weirdly coincidentally the day before
Christine was killed Otto and Pete Otto
and the and the dad had had this huge
argument and Otto had said that I'm
gonna do something that you'll never
forget or something like that they had
like this big fight right so they
assumed that Otto had borrowed the dad's
handkerchief like had the dad's
handkerchief with it with the initials
on it and had killed the little girl
because they had had this huge argument
and a lot
in it yeah so he actually did end up
going and I mean Peter Kurten he didn't
know that he left he just dropped the
handkerchief he wasn't thinking about it
it just so happened that the dad had the
same initials it so happened that Otto
had said that [ __ ] up [ __ ] like just
the day before that happened he got
convicted how many years did he get um
he wasn't he actually they figured out
that he didn't do it before too long
like I think he was in there less than a
year and there wasn't enough evidence so
I think he was actually let go right but
yeah that's like really [ __ ] up did
that happen so don't go around saying
[ __ ] like that like your [ __ ] family
peppers because you never know when
somebody might get murdered coincidental
and you get [ __ ] blame for this [ __ ]
yeah yeah so and another thing that
Peter Kurten did was that the day after
Christine like he killed her he came
back to the scene and he sat at a cafe
across the street from the inn and got a
beer and like sat on the patio and
watched and he listened to people like
around like talking about the murder and
[ __ ] like that and he was like just so
[ __ ] happy about it like like watching
everybody talking about and being all
like freaking out and shocked about it
and wanna so um yeah he said that he was
like really gratified by like all the
disgust and everything that everyone was
like freaking out he also said that
after she was buried that he would go to
visit her grave and that he would um
when he touched the dirt over the coffin
yeah he would blow load yeah no [ __ ]
without even hands-free dan ejaculation
just touching the dirt over the little
girl's coffin or so he said this dude is
completely like oversexed he has like
real problems makes you wander makes you
wonder how how many crimes like this are
prevented by porn by modern porn see I
kind of think it's probably good for you
yeah because I think I think porn did
mystifies all this [ __ ] yeah I mean I
mean we've talked about that before how
I think that
particularly people I mean obviously
people that grow up in like really
violent or abusive
you know not everybody clearly but if
you already have a propensity toward
violence or toward toward not having
inhibitions I guess um and you grow also
grow up in like a horribly abusive
environment that's not gonna go well for
you
this dude's sexualized [ __ ] that isn't
sexual yeah and he seemed to be doing
that from a very very very young age
which the thing about it is that yes he
had a horrible childhood but you have to
think that he had a whole bunch of
siblings and as far as I know none of
them ended up being serial killers even
though they all grew up in the same
horrible environment that he did well
maybe he was a little older during the
time that his dad was there doing all
that [ __ ] up [ __ ] so maybe it impacted
him more because he was old enough for
it to where he could he can actually
have an impact couldn't been the other
ones are so little did they forgot about
it or didn't really impact him the same
way I will note too that his father's
side of the family had a had a genetic
history of various mental illnesses yeah
so there might have been some of that
going on as well like I said not
excusing the dude by any stretch of the
imagination because he [ __ ] knew what
he was doing he knew what he was doing
um and as I said when I write when I
read like a lot of his quotes and stuff
like that he is pretty insightful about
his actions like he doesn't try to
excuse it really or you know other than
saying I just did it revenge because I
got treated so shittily but he he just
didn't really seem to see anything wrong
with it you know what I mean yeah but
definitely a psychopath but he knew that
other people thought it was wrong but he
didn't think it was wrong he's
definitely a psychopath and I think I
think psychopathy is slight it has a
genetic component to it I think it does
as well so you know so it's it's almost
kind of like a form of autism you know
where it has to be I mean it's a person
who I just don't think they can feel any
regular human emotions they don't seem
to be able to feel loved or guilt not
for other people I heard themselves sure
feel it but not for other people that's
why I think and I'll get into this a
little bit later but Peter Kurten did
eventually have a wife and um you know
he never you know a lot of sources say
that oh you know he he never said he
loved her I don't think but he said he
was very fond of her and he like did
things that seemed like he was trying to
help her out and stuff and you know a
lot of sources Sam it's like oh it's so
unusual that he like treated her that
way and everything but I was like I
don't I just don't think that he was
capable of loving a person in the way
that a normal person can love another
person I just I don't think that he
could and I don't think that I I don't
think that he would have thought that he
could I think that he just liked her
because for what she could give him or
because she was like I don't know I got
this guy pegged as a high-functioning
psychopath I definitely think yeah he's
definitely I mean if anyone is a
psychopath this [ __ ] dude is that's
that's for goddamn sure so not too long
after Christine Klein was murdered about
two months later he did the same thing
like he breaks into this other place
like to commit a burglary he had a
skeleton key so I guess he was like
breaking in there into a house in
Dusseldorf and found a 17 year old girl
in there named Gertrude Franken and he
actually strangled her with his bare
hands blood started coming out of her
mouth which made him of course
spontaneously ejaculate and he actually
managed to get out of the house without
anybody seeing him hmm now only a couple
of days after this murder this was on
the 14th 14th of July he got arrested
for a bunch of burglaries and some other
arsons and [ __ ] like that and this time
he got six years now because he was such
an [ __ ] and kept you know being
insubordinate and everything like that
he got another two years tacked on to
that he did this stint in a military
prison in a town called brig so he gets
out in April of 1921 and he goes to
Altenburg and moves in with his sister
for a little while now his sister has a
friend named Augustus Scharf who was a
couple years older than him like I think
she was three years older now she owned
a candy store I think she had worked as
a prostitute in the past she had also
done some prison time because she had a
fiance and either I can't sources differ
either the fiance cheated on her or
promised he was gonna marry her and then
reneged on it so she shot him and killed
him so she had done some she did some
time for that so she had a little bit of
a checkered past as well so her and
Peter Kurten kind of hit it off and you
know so they ended up getting married
two years later now even though they had
sex and everything like that and I guess
she let him do some of the fucked-up
[ __ ] that he wanted to do but he said
later on that the only way that he could
actually get off was to do one of his
like fantasies like fantasize about like
killing everybody or fantasized about
cutting somebody open and like blood
spurting out [ __ ] like that I'm starting
to think about maybe maybe porn wouldn't
help this dude at all
I think this guy's too far gone probably
just show him some porn he probably
wouldn't even be like what's that
yeah it must his sexuality invites sex
and violence must have been and torture
and [ __ ] must have been inexplicably
intertwined yes so early on in his form
if there was no pricing and if you can't
separate I think that's kind of what the
issue was because he had grown up
essentially watching his dad beat and
rape his mother and son in front of him
and some of the sisters um it just
became and then the dehumanizing
elements of [ __ ] like bestiality yeah
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
omni sexuality to where he's just you
know mixed with [ __ ] like pyromania and
[ __ ] sad ism yeah you know he could
say - dude that was his sexuality at
this point yes that's his sexual
orientation I think it started so early
right because there are some things that
if if a kid is so [ __ ] up from like an
early age and that's just all they see
and they don't have any normal you know
they don't have any normal relationships
to look at they don't have any normal
anything but his threshold was way up
here from very beginning so I I don't
know if you can help them know Brian uh
um you know what I mean maybe I mean
maybe you can uh you know I think it's
very rare that somebody is completely
unsalvageable but it's much harder
because ship it like well what are you
gonna do you gonna let a guy like that
walk around society [ __ ] no you know I
said I don't think so either I'm just
I'm talking about not letting him run
around I'm just talking about at least
like leaving him in prison obviously but
if you got somebody to like if he could
work through like with a psychiatrist or
whatever um maybe a double lobotomy and
would actually like be able to
understand like and separate those two
things and understand like why it was
bad and [ __ ] but I don't know math to
this this guy might be one of the few
that I don't think there was any help
something like that Capri only take hold
if you have a [ __ ] strong genetic
component that's kind of what I'm
systematically was probably also a
high-functioning higher because my dad
was with a [ __ ] monster as well so
you have a high IQ high-functioning
psychopath already yeah I mean if his
mind was pretty normal and all that [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] tripped all those [ __ ]
genetic switches in him all that
epigenetics type of [ __ ] came from his
dad and everything you know so now it's
just a perfect storm of a bunch of stuff
that's why these guys are so odd they're
rare that's a bunch of things happening
at once and it's all coming from
different places it's genetic it's
environmental and you know all that
happened and it wants it like you said
becomes a perfect storm that's what this
is I think and as I thought I don't
think it's so many other things you
can't fix it yeah and and very rare it
is very rare I mean you know happily and
I'm not saying that like people having
abusive childhood is rare it's not but
the fact that everything else yeah
everything else it has to have more than
one thing because [ __ ] if everybody that
grew up in like an abusive household
became a serial killer we would be
[ __ ] they'd be all over the place
yeah there would be a lot more of them
than there are now right and also the
abuse is on a spectrum too
you know I mean there's a piece of
families that are nowhere near as bad as
this one yes or no root and bad is that
one so it's on a spectrum yeah so
abusive family isn't enough because if
you're talking about on the light end of
the spectrum that shit's everywhere yeah
that's what I'm saying yeah it's like
you know if if that was just it was
enough to make a serial killer then they
would be all over the place yeah like
most people would be serial killers
because most people had messed-up
childhoods I mean you know and one way
or the other no no there is no
perfection in nature no one had a
perfect upbringing yeah I mean cuz we're
all just humans and we're flawed and we
don't really know what we're doing yeah
your family no matter how special your
mom and dad are - you're the man no
matter how much you hate him or whatever
they're random people you didn't choose
him most people just have random family
yeah like you know I look at my dad my
dad's cool dude but he's just random
yeah he just happens to be my dad yeah
and it affected a lot my life and
upbringing because it but it could have
been somebody else yeah that'd have been
different but it's just random you know
I mean your mom's random yeah it's a
random [ __ ] thing it is you don't
extreme she's right which is what's kind
of scary because you don't know who are
gonna [ __ ] it up with when I look next I
look at my extended family okay like
like aunts and uncles on both sides of
the family there's just [ __ ] random
people yeah I know I'm real well yeah
there were just they could be
interchanged with any other people -
right you know and I mean yeah
what's kind of funny you know what I
mean you take it for granted but if you
really if you're really objective about
it there month different just [ __ ]
random people well guess what you're
random - well yeah where everybody's
just kind of read we're all ready we're
all [ __ ] ready but we have we'll all
right we have will we have skills and
you have with some people don't have
well but most people have some kind of
willpower you can shape yourself into
whatever you want if you have enough
[ __ ] willpower a lot of successful
[ __ ] have defied their random
[ __ ] families and become an in
achieved excellence it's been a lot of
that
a lot of excellent [ __ ] have
some random-ass or bad families so you
can't let that hold you back well that's
why I said I I've always been a big
advocate of cuz I know that there's some
maybe not so much nowadays but I know
that there was a school of thought where
it's like oh family like blood is
thicker than water and family is
everything and families but see I've
always been a big advocate of like you
said your family they just randomly had
to have you didn't choose that [ __ ] yeah
so I mean my family are lovely but if
you if you grew up in a super [ __ ] up
family I do not think that you should
feel one scintilla of guilt about
cutting those [ __ ] out of your
life if they are talking just cut them
right out don't feel bad about it you
don't let other people make you feel bad
about it's like oh you know my mom
abused me my dad abused me this I don't
[ __ ] talk to this writer [ __ ] anymore
like you don't have to yeah I I'm a big
advocate of that like go find yourself a
good family go find friends go find
people you picked that you like you know
what I mean go do that those are just
people that had you you don't you don't
have any obligation to them and I
remember growing up you know all my
aunts and uncles you kind of you kind of
I they're kind of idealized in your mind
yeah but then as you get older so should
we start getting in your 40s and 50s
some more you find out about him the
more you realize that they're just like
everybody else really well yeah
everybody's there just random it's like
one of the thing is and you know I love
my mom my mom is awesome um she had me
when she was really young she was only
just out of high school and um she once
told me when I was in my 30s probably I
never thought about it cuz well you know
we grew up poor and stuff like that but
my mom was like always like super cool I
never like felt like I was deprived or
anything and she once said to me like
when I was in my late 30s she said man
she's like I'm paraphrasing but she said
I'm really glad she turned out okay
because I had no idea what I was doing
yeah she was just out of high school and
she had a baby she didn't really know
and I was like you know and she'd been
holding that within like all that time
but I was just like mom you did fine you
know I mean it's like I haven't killed
anybody I'm not on drugs I'm not you
know it's like it's fine you're cool and
honestly I have three other siblings and
they all turned out awesome too so she's
a good job even though she's no choose
to go there so she said I just thought
that was very funny
yes oh so he marries this woman and you
know like I said he can only like kind
of get off by thinking about [ __ ] and of
course um he cheated on her all over the
place
he actually although he did actually get
a job for pretty much the first time in
his life he worked as a I think your
trades union official or something like
that and he had he started an affair
with a servant girl named Tita and also
a house maid so he was had a whole bunch
of women always [ __ ] digs in his pants
no he really couldn't and you know what
I mean
and those two women I guess they allowed
him to do the whole choking thing he had
a Chokin kind of thing um now his wife
found out about him like Cattin around
and one of the women actually called the
police on him and said that he had
seduced her one also claimed rape which
I buy it because he did that kind of
[ __ ] all the time so he actually ended
up getting eight months on the seduction
charge which I did this adduction I
guess that's illegal
yeah why in Germany at that time well
now I think that might be like a
euphemism for I don't know if it's a
euphemism for a rape or for sexual
assault I'd be like strong-arm a sexual
assault that's kind of what I'm thinking
I don't think it's like seduction like
ooh hey baby
she's like their Channel they're talking
about sexual so I'm yeah I'm thinking
that that's kind of go up there and grab
a [ __ ] go I'm gonna take a [ __ ] yeah
and then you start [ __ ] grabbing her
and she'll like you don't actually rape
her but you're manhandling her that's
what that's what they're talking yeah
which is sexual assault so yeah so he
rightly went to prison for that so he
got he got eight months but he only
served six because they said okay well
we'll let you out but you have to leave
Dusseldorf
so he said okay but then like he
appealed it and they said okay well you
can come back so there you go all right
so do you want to take a break now a
little bit right - I noticed your drink
was getting kind of empty mine's pretty
full cuz I've been talking the whole
time but alright so we have a strong
drink it's just
to hit me right now he's trying to hold
he's gonna start swaying around the
chair and the cameras gonna go out of
focus like I'm gonna have to keep quiet
the rest of the show yeah yeah yeah yeah
you'll be all right yeah all right so
we're gonna take a break and we'll be
back in just a couple minutes
oh yeah you [ __ ] out of that yeah you
vanquished it poopy okay
she was I got it cause she used to like
she went on cords
it's got cat in it she likes to rub it
on her face
you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
baby's case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
all right we're back talking about Peter
Kurten the vampire Dusseldorf
yeah it's been a [ __ ] wild story so
far I can't believe I've never heard of
this guy he should have been famous here
in the United States you think that I
mean there's a lot of kind of European
serial killers that did some really
fucked-up [ __ ] particularly the first
half of the 20th century and I'm like
surprised that more people haven't heard
about them well it was over a hundred
years ago this happened so it's easy to
forget yeah that's true but it's like
you would I mean you know people still
remember what [ __ ] Jack the Ripper
did
yeah the Ripper that was a long time ago
he had good press I think the thing
about Jack the Ripper is that they never
caught him so it's like you can come on
everyone [ __ ] then they made all
kinds of movies about yeah we still have
to see that damn was it time after time
no not too much oh yeah time after time
we viewed it we don't have it on [ __ ]
blu-ray though yeah I know I wanna I
want to see it again I've seen that
movie like so many times that I have
memorized it
yeah but David Warner makes a great
[ __ ] Jack the Ripper I am yes this is
good yeah
so Peter curtains um
banner year if you want to call it that
for serial killing the year but he just
kind of said he seemed he seemingly just
said [ __ ] it and went around committing
all the crime that he could get away
with was 1929 so he started pretty early
February 3rd 1929 he sees an elderly
lady in Apollonia [ __ ] walking down the
street waits till she's gone behind some
bushes so that like passers-by can't see
her jumps on her grabs her by the coat
lapels and screams in her face don't
scream and then he drags her into like
some bushes and [ __ ] like that and stabs
her 24 times damn she should have
screamed with a sharpened pair of
scissors yeah she shoulda scream now
even though she lived even though like a
lot of the stab wounds like went down to
her bones these were like like [ __ ]
deep stab wounds but she did live
lucky yeah she was well how
how lucky she was I guess she was lucky
to live yeah now only a few days later
five days later a matter of fact Peter
Kurten strangled a nine-year-old girl
named Rosa Olinger he pretty much he
strangled her until she went unconscious
and then started stabbing her with the
scissors stabbed her in the stomach
stabbed her in the temple which was kind
of a thing for him he liked to stab
people in the head like in the front of
their head stabbed her in the vagina
also stabbed her in the heart and while
he was stabbing her guess what
spontaneous ejaculation so he takes this
little girl's body and like drags it
kind of under a hedge like to hide it I
guess and then like a couple hours later
he comes back and it seemed like he
attempted to set the body on fire like
he came back like with a little bottle
of gasoline or something and set it on
fire had another orgasm watching the
body burn although according to dr. Berg
the body didn't burn all the way like
the clothes burned the skin on the
thighs burn all her hair burned off but
I guess the fire went out like before it
consumed the body completely it's hard
to burn a body you can't really burn a
body with gasoline there's too much
fluid in it yeah I'm not sure if it was
gasoline or kerosene I've seen like
sources saying both wouldn't matter I
mean that but I went with dr. Berg and
he said gasoline or petrol yeah so so
I'm assuming that's what he was talking
about but um yeah so I guess I don't
know if he really wanted to just destroy
the body or if you just got off on the
flames themselves because it seemed like
he was just like this - yeah but that's
what I mean it so many burn right so I
don't think like he was really all that
concerned about he didn't really seem
concerned about getting caught because
he just like would go up and stab
Brandon [ __ ] in the street I
saw an indian dude set himself on fire
it's just like recently you know this is
one of those old films just like he did
he was some kind of protest I don't
really understand it pour gasoline on
himself and he had a lighter like he was
gonna set himself on fire and he may
have been threatening to set
cellphone Ferrari he went up anyway I
think an accidental flying got him and
he burned up and man it was his clothes
fell off he was wearing like a real
light come on sorry tight thing his
clothes fell off and his skin just
snapped like a damn sheet of rubber back
off of his body well yeah it's like any
it's like pork cracklins yeah it fell
off his body white was standing there on
fire and then the fire went out and he
was still standing there a lot of skin
on yeah that's why he thought I didn't
lose er well no man I always thought
like that's the [ __ ] worst wavelength
east of like burn those poor women alive
like because they said they were witches
and all that kind of it that's gotta be
the worst [ __ ] worst way to go in this
guy terrible I just thought this dude I
just thought you know I mean like I feel
sorry for him but I feel pitiful in a
way but I must feel anger at him you
know what I mean did she and it was over
something that's kind of stupid he
thought he was gonna set himself on fire
in an act of defiance and that it would
kill him
well like the monkey feel like
protesting the Vietnam yeah those those
dudes died they did this dude here the
flames went out quickly and then he was
just standing there without any damn
skin the [ __ ] in agony for [ __ ] a
long time and now he's gonna live like
that and I was like you [ __ ] down the
ass I mean if you're gonna like
seriously if you're gonna set yourself
on fire
pull yourself in make sure you die make
sure you [ __ ] make sure you die fairly
quickly because you don't want to live
it
that's what I mean that's what I people
like that um Bieber would [ __ ] watch
that documentary about Kane Hodder and
he got like really Rhett badly burned
like early in his career and he was
talking about how [ __ ] horrible that
is yeah that has got to be one of the
worst yeah things too and and even if
you live it's just oh I just can't
imagine like you would never recover
from that because you know if you live
long enough you're gonna change your
mind about doing that like I should have
done it and you're gonna feel played as
[ __ ] yeah and I mean at least that dude
at Burning Man that ran into that big
old bonfire died at least he died and he
didn't live
he didn't he probably went out very
quickly and all that heat he ran right
into that fire like a champ
didn't even know what he was doing I
think he did yeah but here's the thing
he died therefore he didn't have to time
to regret it didn't have to lay around
lay around like that [ __ ] I was dumb as
[ __ ] now I think he wanted to kill
himself and I and I think he was in a
celebration too that he wanted to kill
himself and that everybody who's seen it
yeah I believe I mean maybe somebody dug
up that guy's identity you know maybe it
was more of a tragic story than that but
from what I saw dude looked happy to run
into that fire and he just winked out
both cuz you know I mean he went into
the damn fire underneath all that stack
wood imagine how hot that was you
couldn't feel it especially under those
drugs that's not really for people that
have survived really bad burns that's
like I feel like they've said those like
that's the worst
yeah ever yeah but the the pain is after
yeah it was after the burning a lot of
times the adrenaline and this dude was
on all kinds of [ __ ] drugs he had to
them try on [ __ ] LSD and all kinds of
other drugs he probably didn't feel he
was just a lot man look how great it is
the flames you know like a bug going
into a damn bug zapper remember the bug
zappers in the back here that's what I
like oh like I said all the poor women
they used to burn at the stake and stuff
like that I'm like I always kind of hope
they just died from smoke inhalation
well they did everything I think
immediately they've got a smoke
inhalation but they were burned there
were a lot of their body before the
smoke inhalation God so you know that's
what I mean it's like one of them was if
you're gonna kill yourself
goddamn there's like a lot better ways
to yeah we're hopefully and then if you
[ __ ] it up and you don't like go through
with it all the way to have to live with
[ __ ] agony and scar tissue for your
entire life
easiest ways guns or drugs yeah I'm just
saying overdose yeah just take a whole
sleep you don't have to do that you
could just suck it and pour a whole
[ __ ] bottle a damn vodka down your
throat you won't survive that yeah
that's true yeah that might be actually
kind of enjoying it come on so faster
your body can't [ __ ] my body can't
[ __ ] compensate for it yeah you
[ __ ] die kills you
I mean you could just chug a whole
bottle of vodka and like you could throw
some I'm just saying maybe we gotta cut
this out I think it's like I'm just
saying that like people that do that I
don't know why you would choose to do it
in the most painful [ __ ] it some people
feel that they've done wrong and they
want to suck and they want to suffer
yeah I get that I was in Boston my
neighbor and my partner she was not a
forgot her name that's there forever
since I thought that spoken to her she
was a mental health professional and she
dealt with outpatients mental help
outpatients and a lot of them would kill
themselves with fire or some did and
because they felt like they deserved it
it felt like the deserve [ __ ] in the
past I get that a lot of it was like
it's actually even less than other
people that type of stuff when they were
younger and you know they were victims
of like sexual assault and then they
would did prison time and then maybe
mental time in a mental [ __ ] health
institution you know and then they just
kind of give up and well this is this
one girl that should that is what she
would dump that girl she was molesting
other people and then she was molested
and she gave up and she poured gasoline
all over her [ __ ] bed one time and
set herself on fire killed her
yeah but that's why she felt she had to
suffer for what she had done
yeah she couldn't I mean I can
understand they want to go out in agony
yeah but she was also like basically
schizophrenic - she wasn't an old person
yeah so it was a bunch of stuff at once
yeah so yeah so he tried to said this
little girl's body on fire they found
the body the next day like I said it was
a little bit burned but not all that
bird because the fire had gone out only
a few days after that actually
five days after that on the 13th of
February he actually just ran up behind
this 45 year old dude a mechanic whose
name was Rudolph Scheer he just ran up
behind him and started stabbing him with
his [ __ ] scissors stabbed him in the
head stabbed in the back stem and the
eyes all this other kind of [ __ ] so he
killed him now
when the cops again here's the thing
like you were saying about arsonists
when the cops found the body
Peter Kurten shows up to the site and he
says Oh some somebody that lives around
here told me about the crime what's
going on you know what I mean so he
comes he turns up at the body site and
like he's like trying to help out the
cops or like asking them what's going on
and [ __ ] like that so he did definitely
have that thing now this is another
thing where I think that maybe the
German police might have been kind of on
the ball because even though this was
three different victim profiles if he
will note this is an elderly woman a
nine-year-old girl and a middle-aged man
however the investigators did note that
the attacks had all happened at about
the same time of day you know about best
like early evening all of them had
involved like stabbing multiple times
like in quick succession none of them
had had robbery involved and all of the
victims appeared to have been chosen at
random so the investigators were pretty
sure that this was the same person so
that's pretty good because I do feel
like a lot of crimes of this nature
particularly if it's not because you
know I've written about a lot of crimes
where you know in Europe and the US and
stuff like that if all the victims
aren't the same type like if they're not
all like you know prostitutes in their
20s or if they're not all like children
earth and all like they don't really
link the crimes together but it does
feel like the German police were yeah
these are all related you know what I
mean because the the mo was too similar
even though the victim profiles were
completely different so now between
March in July 1929 it did seem that
Peter Kurten attempted several other
murders I think it was four women that
he tried to strangle
he said that he threw one of them into
the wrong river but none of these women
died the next murder that he committed
wasn't until August 11th now this was a
woman named Maria Kahn now he actually
met her on August 8th um I guess he I
don't know how he met her exactly but he
said that she was a girl looking for
marriage so I don't know if he had like
met her through an ad or something like
that like where he asked her out on a
date so he was going to take her out on
a date on the following Sunday like
after he met her after he responded her
ad or whatever so he hung out with her
like pretty much all day they were like
you know walking around the city like
whatever they were and then he like
lures are into this meadow near like it
was in Dusseldorf but it was in like the
Neanderthal region you know what I mean
so he said that he lures her into this
meadow she started to get suspicious um
and she started like begging she's like
hey like don't hurt me don't kill me or
whatever but then he started strangling
her stabbed her in the head again
because that was like a thing because he
liked all the blood coming out you know
I guess he was like into like all the
blood spurting out of the wound or
whatever not drinking any of this he did
some of them not until later though
there was only one or two that like he
actually drank that he admitted later
that he drank the blood which is why
eats called Abed yeah he was just like a
blood guy like he yeah he said later
that he got like a tremendous amount of
sexual gratification from the site and
the sound of blood spurting out of her
wound like he really really got off on
that yeah you know I think um so yes so
he stabbed her in the chest after the
head and then he sits on top of her and
like just looks at her and waits for her
to expire but um and it took about an
hour for her to die
like she was just laying there now he
got like I guess he'd had like blood
like on his clothes like from an earlier
attack and like his wife had seen it and
was like it was kind of like where'd you
get the blood from and he had like
Meghan
like you know make up some excuse or
whatever it was yeah although she didn't
know that he was actually the vampire of
Dusseldorf until later on she knew that
he was [ __ ] around on her she knew
that and she knew that he had done some
bad [ __ ] in the past I mean she had
killed the dude in the past too um but I
don't think she realized the extent of
it because I mean she didn't realize she
didn't put two and two together by the
strangling and fetishes and all that no
not really I don't think she did I don't
think she did its well because and I
think we talked about this on a few of
the other shows maybe BTK and stuff like
that like serial killers that were like
married and had a family life and
whatever um it does seem in hindsight
that how could this person not know it's
like they live with this person and like
how do you be but one you don't want to
believe that anyone you're actually in a
relationship someone you've known for
like X amount of years it's actually
running around being a serial killer
like I don't think anyone wants to think
that or you know even if it's not
someone like you're not your significant
other maybe it's somebody your family
your brother your sister or whatever and
you don't want to think that about that
person because you know them and it's
like they would never do anything like
that um also you know like I said before
particularly when you know dudes like go
out to work or they go out and do
whatever they're doing and particularly
back in the old days when you weren't
really like supposed to question them
just like hey I'm going at my job I'm
going out to the pub or whatever and you
weren't supposed to like ask them what
they were up to
you wouldn't [ __ ] know what they were
doing out there I mean they could say
they were going to the pub they could
say they were going to work and they
could be doing all kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you wouldn't know about look at what
[ __ ] BTK was doing yeah his wife
didn't know about any of that [ __ ] his
kids didn't know any about that [ __ ] I
think when she here he would Ridgway -
yeah why would you it's like you
wouldn't suspect that and particularly
when they come across as fairly normal
as Peter Kurten seemed to come across as
a fairly normal person he like I said he
looked real dapper like he was always
dressed very neatly like he's always
wearing a suit
we said his hair was all nice and
everything like that so and he was like
kind of charming and [ __ ]
a lot of Psychopaths have that they have
that kind of like easy charm they're
very you know ingratiating so I can see
how you would just like not think that
somebody like that because I still think
that people expect that criminals are
serial killers and stuff like that are
gonna look like monsters or like weirdos
and not all of them do most of them look
like dorks yeah look at Gary Ridgway and
not all of them come across as weirdos
when you talk to them some of them do I
mean you know what I mean but I do feel
like some of the ones that get away with
it for a long time some of the ones that
are straight-up Psychopaths that's the
whole thing with Psychopaths is that
they are so used to like you know
mimicking human emotions that they can
fool a lot of people they don't come
across as weird they come across as just
like a normal person sounds so much like
my stepdad well that's the weird thing
is the funny thing and I think we
mentioned this we did the show on Ted
Bundy is that even though he really did
seem to come across as normal but I did
note that he seemed to come across as
normal to dudes
women that knew him other than his
girlfriend seemed to think he was a
little creepy yeah they seem to get that
like hey like weird vibe try looking at
them [ __ ] sideways that's what I mean
yeah and I don't you and plus I do feel
like women are more attuned to body
language and stuff body language and
like why is that dude looking at me like
that why is that dude like crossing the
street like over here and why is that
because you always have to be like alert
to what random dudes are doing around
you because you don't know which one of
them is Ted Bundy so you definitely do
have to be like more attuned to that I
guess than guys have to be so maybe
that's why but this really does seem
like a case where Peter Kurten seemed to
come across as a normal enough guy that
he could get away with doing this kind
of crap although like I said
he was at this point in 1929 he was just
coming up to like random people on the
street and just like dragging him into
bushes and stabbing him so he decides
he's gonna go because he didn't want his
wife finding out about this [ __ ] he's
like well I don't want this body to be
found yet so I'm gonna [ __ ] hide it
somewhere so he takes um
Maria han and he buries her like in this
cornfield and nobody finds it for like a
whole bunch of weeks and he keeps going
back I don't think he's a necrophile
like the the psychologist said I don't
think he he's a necrophile exactly um
but he does seem to like to go back to
the scene and like think about what he
did and it gets him off to think about
it
well what he did in Maria Hans case was
a couple weeks after he killed her and
buried her in this cornfield he goes
back to the cornfield and he said that
what he had planned to do he was going
to dig her up and crucify her on a tree
because he just thought that would be
neat like a neat thing to do so he
either tried to do it or thought about
doing it and then he's like oh well I
guess they need another person to do
this because it's too hard to like lift
deadweight up and then like nail it to
the tree like you know what I mean like
he can't hold it up there and nail her
bro I guess like wrist of the tree and
he like couldn't do it so he said okay
well he's full of [ __ ] though yeah you
know because you because you can clean a
deer one man yeah I mean a deer might
weigh a hundred pounds 120 pounds he's
just not thinking of it he might be in
[ __ ] cuz you can do it with a winch
you can witch him up there with the
right equipment and the ladder and lash
him with rope and then nail him and then
well maybe he thought that that would
attract I don't know how you don't have
to do and brute force but he was just
saying that it's like oh well I guess I
can't really you know just do it by
myself or like you know not the way I
want to do it so he said well what he
did then was he just went back to the
site and he dug the body up and like
laid underneath it and then like how
long had it been buried a couple weeks
yeah and she was right so he did dig it
up it was dug up yeah
and he said yeah because the body wasn't
found for a little while and he said
later on like after he had caught he
said that he kept returning to the grave
and quote-unquote improving upon it he's
bullshitting he was having sex with it
he yeah I think that like like I said
the psychologist said that he didn't
think that he was like a straight-up
necrophile but he did seem to have some
[ __ ] and necrophorum that regard the
same [ __ ] Gary Ridgway was doing yeah we
got a few weeks later he's like why
because it was free right exactly
he was already there yeah well like I
said I mean Peter Kurten seemed to have
a real big thing about thinking about
killing the person and so I think for
him I don't know if it was necrophilia
exactly I think it was just him
remembering what he had done and like
this is the result of it and like
remembering like the blood gushing out
and remembering and that would like get
him off because he had like a really um
vivid imagination apparently and he
really really liked to come amongst
these fantasies about the killings and
he would go back to the scene and just
think about it he said it's kind of like
looking at photographs of some chick
that you screwed or or maybe photographs
of sex you had with some chick yeah
there's a man if that's what it's like
then that means that [ __ ] is jerking
off to it well yeah you know what I mean
see maybe he's not actually having sex
with the body but I think he probably
was at least he's jerking off to it oh
yeah I don't think I don't think he
would have denied that exactly I don't
think he would have said that he had sex
with the bodies but I don't think he
would have denied that he like would
ejaculate thinking about it but here I'm
gonna take it a step further though if
you're gonna dig it up and jerk off to
it and it's there why not just have sex
with it that's what I'm saying he's
having sex with the dead body he's just
not admitted to it yeah that's what I'm
just saying
no to Charlie [ __ ] and even though
this it's a perverse concept I'm trying
to look at it as a man you not a man and
as a man I'm telling you well if you're
gonna go through all that now you're
into that thing you're gonna go ahead
and have sex with it as well
if Gary Ridgway did it then that means
that other guys were doing it and Gary
Ridgway because it was free Gary Ridgway
was having sex with it when it was
[ __ ] rotten yeah and even when it
smelled yeah
and we're talking like weeks and weeks
and we all that bumping up and that
means it also had maggots in it yeah and
he was going back and the water was
right there so you could wash himself
off and he's put his clothes back on and
then gone back to his wife and put his
Peter into that wife [ __ ] after he
was in the back just saying
and I'm saying we did Gary Ridgway show
it's like do we even mention this cuz
what's the wife ever kind of like why
smell corpsey I'm thinking he had you
know how to have rape kits and he must
have had like a necro kid that he
brought with him like a bottle of bottle
of shampoo and all kinds of [ __ ]
cologne and [ __ ] so he could take off
all his clothes have sex with this
rotting body and then get his kit and
take it out into the [ __ ] water
because the water was there and [ __ ]
take a bath and get all that stink off
of him and then come out dry off and
then [ __ ] get back into his clothes
put it all in the bag and then leave go
back into the car that he had it all
planned ahead think of all this think of
all the productive [ __ ] you could do if
you use all that energy for planning all
of this stupid crap that you ever do I
think
Ridgeway would be at work thinking about
that hot dead body that girl laying out
there go on it she's still out there I
ought to be getting that yeah I mean
yeah it's like she's just laying there
just laying down there right so then
he's coming up with a what do I need
what do I need what do I have to do you
know get that and they get away with it
again so he comes up with his necro kid
I mean you think was that kind of stick
you would need like some [ __ ] comet
and like [ __ ] brillo pad yeah I would
think he probably went out there and
tested it probably some [ __ ] like lava
soap you know the man
lava soap rags alcohol you know maybe
some bleach water in a spray bottle and
spray that [ __ ] and towels yeah and then
Ziploc bags to put the towels in so the
dirty towels don't contaminate the rest
of the bag you've thought too much about
this no clean too dear and I have NBC
China from the Army nuclear biological
and chemical and you have to keep
contaminated items of we have
uncontaminated those so you know smell
is a sign of contamination
yeah so being being a necro perv you're
gonna have to start thinking in terms
yeah so that's what he probably did yeah
just a weird thing to like occupy your
mind thinking about it's all I'm saying
well he's working sin he's fantasizing
about that hot dead booty sitting out
there you know I mean so he's thinking
what is it I happened to go back there
you said three seconds on that note I'm
up yeah and then because he can get
three seconds he's dead to kill again
it's just sitting there and then he
successfully gets away with it he goes a
lot what about thirds yes and then the
next thing you know you know she's been
out there for about three months ninety
days you know I mean she was awful soft
last time I saw her you know I mean so
and then he starts a Rotter sizing that
he's got a minute I was head of section
with her in her arm broke off you know
that was so high he probably did think
that yeah you know I mean I'm trying to
put myself
and his man's feet I'll try to put this
man in his mansion actually that's kind
of more apropos like considering that
we're talking about probably maybe he's
got to be naked when this is all going
on I didn't really want to think about
Gary Ridgway naked so thank you for that
you can't get some of that grave booty
with clothes on it's gonna get your
clothes to grave well obviously it's
gonna get your clothes taken yeah so
that means he didn't have shoes on or
anything now I'm just now I have this
horrible mental picture like [ __ ]
scrawny ass Gary Ridgway wow this is
like [ __ ] white ass butt cheeks yeah
with his shoes off and it's closing a
nice neat pile and then he walks out to
the body with the flies you gotta
[ __ ] get the flies off of majesty
some people really have issues right
well this dude was like that I bet you
dad down in the Gradius he was like that
down the graveyard thinking about it you
know she's pretty hot you know she's
dead now she's having to put up a fight
or anything oh my god do is dig her up
and not gonna have like a second or
third run on that maybe 4th you're right
right right
it's free he's thinking yeah like I said
it seems such a shame yeah you letting
it waste
yeah he's frugal yeah yeah I I wish I
could just like every single one of the
dudes that we have done shows about I
wish I could just lick I'm trying to
rash ate them I'm trying to rationalize
it you know I mean the behavior trying
to put myself in his position
yeah I'm trying to put my normal
masculine motives you know I mean into
these perverse motives
you tried I'm trying to just say the
victim is like just some hot girl you
want a date and you want to have sex
with her but in his case he's already
killed it yeah that doesn't necessarily
mean he doesn't still want a date yeah
so you have to so she remains the same
that you know I mean so what would you
do
just because she's dead doesn't mean you
still don't want it yeah so how do you
go about this that's got to be what he's
going through I would imagine it right I
mean I can't think of any other destiny
rushing and I think that's probably like
you said I think that's the case
pert near to Peter yeah that you know
there has to be some kind of little bit
of necrophiliacs something or other
weeks later and be like ham like I'm
gonna mess with the body I'm gonna lay
underneath it and get some quote unquote
satisfaction from that he put her on top
and he was screwing her that's what
there's going on and she was dead yeah
probably
you see this is like he's using them
kind of like porn all right
but it's 3d well it's like a blow-up
doll
right except with maggots right well
eventually and it's probably a slow
process where you're accepting more and
more you're accepting more and more of
this necro dynamic yes right the necro
game that'd be a great make a [ __ ]
t-shirt the neck road we're gonna be
watching some hot [ __ ] really hot
chick she just happens to be dead it's
like don't be so racist racist at all
weird
alright we're talking about a weird
[ __ ]
he is a weird so I'm just trying to
analyze it and give you my take on it
and then bring that take to the masses
yeah you know it's gotta be what it is
it's gotta be what they're thinking yeah
I imagine it probably is I mean people
people like Peter Kurten particularly
and some of these other serial killers
too it's like there it seems like their
sex drive is way way way like overboard
and that's like their whole entire like
focus in life like because like I said
you know I do the [ __ ] on Instagram if
you guys know I do like Dennis's sexual
problems like yeah and everything and
some of the weird [ __ ] that he says it
just seems like his entire life is based
around his weird sexual fantasies he has
like code names for everything he has
acronyms for everything it just seems
like that is what his entire being is
tied up with which is very weird to me
it's like a nice mini like everybody has
a sex drive that's normal but the fact
that it's just this all-consuming force
and it just drives you to do these
things and you come up with these
[ __ ] elaborate scenarios
it's just that is [ __ ] crazy to me
that's why I'm saying this whole story
about him laying under it and every this
is just a [ __ ] youth euphemism that's
what he's telling the investigators
that's not what happened he put her up
on top of there was [ __ ] boning her
the investigators didn't check well yeah
I wonder if early 1900 guys are gonna
start digging around an old dead vag
yeah but that's what that's what
happened so so he apparently did this
for a while and then finally three
months after he killed her he sent a
letter anonymously to the cops and said
that he did it and he drilled like a
little
like where her body was and even though
the map was kind of shitty like it was
good enough that the police actually did
find the body now after he had killed
Maria [ __ ]
I guess Peter Kurten decided well I
better change my MO or change my weapon
of choice so that the police won't catch
me so for a while he'd been stabbing
everybody with scissors now he decided
that he was going to start killing
people with a hammer so you know in an
effort to like disguise that it was the
same person yeah um but he did actually
still kind of like use a scissors
sometimes but he kind of like changed it
up I guess
so on August 21st he finds an 18 year
old girl walking down the street stabs
her also stabs a 30 year old man in a 37
year old woman this was all like on the
same day he's just like run around like
stabbing spree yeah this is essentially
like a spree he's just like freaking out
he all of them lived now they were able
to like give like a loose description
but they of him to the police but they
all said look this dude just like he
didn't say anything he just like walked
up and like [ __ ] started stabbing now
three days after this which was you know
August 24th he was um at a fairground
and he saw two little girls who were
foster sisters one of them was five and
one of them was 14 and they were walking
home from the fairground so he goes up
to them and he takes like the older girl
he's 14 her name is Louise London and he
gave her some money and said hey why
don't you go back to the fairground and
buy me some cigarettes so she did and
then he takes the little girl the five
year old and he picks her up and like
takes her off in the bushes and
strangled her and then cut her throat
and then threw her body into like a
patch of beans or some [ __ ]
now when her foster sister comes back um
he starts strangling her as well and
then start stabbing her in the chest one
of the wounds penetrated her heart her
aorta
and he also and this is where he got the
vampire of Dusseldorf thing he also bit
and cut her throat and then started
sucking blood from the wounds hmm um so
neither of these girls was sexually
assaulted so it does seem like he was
just and like I said some of the earlier
ones like what he would do was he would
just like spontaneously ejaculate while
he was killing them and then sometimes
he would just like take his [ __ ] [ __ ]
covered hand and like stick his fingers
in their vaginas and stuff like he would
do that kind of [ __ ] like a surrogate
yeah it's almost kind of like he's like
not sexually functional he is that all I
mean according to like his wife and all
his mistresses okay because he had a
[ __ ] ton of mistresses too
that's true so it wasn't like he was
impotent because serial killers are and
they just kind of like you know because
I feel like vtk had a little bit of that
going on too because he didn't really
like rape and need the victims like
sometimes he would like jizz on them or
into their underwear or something like
that but he didn't like rape them this
whole thing was control tying a [ __ ] up
and control like that yeah I think and I
think it's the same kind of thing with
this guy it just seems like he got off
so much on the blood flow and on the
ceiling that he didn't need to rape them
essentially I mean he did rape some of
the victims but it does seem like he was
so excited just by on a big charge out
of it
Adams a killing itself that he didn't
even really need to do that then he goes
up to another woman who was 27 her name
was Gertrude Sholto now he just goes up
to her and like [ __ ] Bold As Brass
just say to her says to her
hey have sex with me she says reportedly
I'd rather die yeah and he says well die
then then he starts stabbing her in the
[ __ ] head in the neck and everything
now she actually did survive although
she couldn't give a real good
description of him she said he was like
middle aged and he was like not all that
you know he wasn't all that memorable
looking that's basically what
she said um he also did two more
attempted murders after that one he
attempted to strangle one he attempted
to stab that was in September neither of
those victims died and then he decided
he was just gonna go full-on hammer
attacks from this point forward
so xxx this September hmm he runs into
this 31 year old servant girl named Ida
Reuter and this was at a train station I
believe in Dusseldorf now he basically
said hey why don't you just like come to
me like I said he was actually quite
charming and not a bad-looking dude so
she said hey come to come with me to a
cafe and then they're gonna go for a
walk like through this like park or
whatever and then when they're walking
through the park he decides he's just
gonna start [ __ ] hitting her in the
head so he just like starts hitting her
in the head with a [ __ ] hammer um
both during and after he raped her so he
did rape this victim hmm now 11 days
after that which was October 11th he
runs into another servant girl who was
22 or her name was Elizabeth Dori a this
was outside of a theater um
again he kind of asked her for a date
like hey come to this cafe have a drink
with me have a coffee or whatever so she
goes with him then they took a train
then they took a walk and then he
started beating her around the head with
a hammer and left her for dead
now she didn't die immediately although
she did die the next day like they found
her she was still alive and they took
her to the hospital but she was in a
coma and she never woke up and they come
and she died the next day
October 25th he attacked two more women
with a hammer both survived in this in
the case of the second woman it was
because the hammer that he was using
broke while he was attacking her now
November 7th
1929 he finds a five-year-old girl named
Gertrude olbermann walking down the
street and says hey why don't you come
with me over here to like where these
houses are like well all these houses
were like empty and then he picks her up
by the throat and strangled her and then
stabbed her in the head with a pair of
scissors
and then stabbed her further 34 times in
the head and chest and then left her in
a pile of Nettles
now by this time like I said the
investigators were pretty sure all of
these attacks were perpetrated by the
same person who at this point they had
started to call the vampire of
Dusseldorf and it gotten like it was in
all the papers in Germany it was
actually like all the way around the
world like it was big big news so they
basically um the investigators like I
said they think this is the same person
they're like asking the public like what
is going on like please give us some
tips and stuff like that so they get
like 13,000 letters like claiming they
know that guy is um they just like going
through like pursuing all the leads and
everything 9,000 dinner interviews were
undertaken with various persons of
interest witnesses suspects whatever and
they compiled a list of 900,000 names of
potential suspects in this case so they
were actually doing their due diligence
and going through but there was like so
many people to get through that it was
just like taking them forever so now two
days after this five year old little
girl was killed Richard Oberman so this
other newspaper gets a map saying where
Maria Hans body is which as you know if
you'll remember like he had sent one to
another newspaper earlier as well and he
also included a map in this letter of
where he left Gertrude all over his body
which the police had already found now
they actually gave the two letters to a
graphologist he was like a handwriting
analysis specialist and like I said they
determined that these two letters had
members by the same person and so that
was like more you know evidence that
they you know what they already
suspected that these attacks were all
perpetrated by the same person because
the handwriting looked the same
so between February and May of 1930
you know Peter Kurten engaged in a bunch
of other attacks none of which were
fatal thankfully but many of them were
hammer attacks and attempted
strangulations
this ended up being a total of ten
victims all of which survived
um and all of them were able to describe
their attacker to the police as well so
they did have like a description of what
he looked like
goes to show I guess a hammers and all
that deadly yeah it was just kind of
like when we talked about like the Axman
of New Orleans and [ __ ] like that I was
like amazed that so many people could be
struck in the head with an axe blade and
still survive and beat mostly okay like
other than maybe losing some teeth right
but yeah but like it's weird because
most of like the axe man of New Orleans
I was under the impression that like he
had just killed all the tree he did kill
a bunch of people but a lot of his most
of his victims survived even though they
were struck in the head with an axe
which that was like freaking me out I
don't know I just always thought like
axe was just like [ __ ] split your
head open immediately but so okay May
13th May 14th rather 1930 so there's
this woman named Maria Budd like she's
20 years old and she is at Dusseldorf
station the train station now this guy
comes up to her and he finds out he's
like oh well she's on her way to
Dusseldorf she's looking for you know
she's just moved there she's looking for
work she's looking for a place to stay
so this guy says hey I'll show you where
there's like a hostel you can stay up on
the block so she's like all right so she
starts going with him and he starts like
trying to lead her through this park
we're like not a lot of people work so
she's kind of like yeah this seems a
little sketchy and they started fighting
like arguing and you would think that
that guy was Peter Kurten but it wasn't
this guy was Peter Kurten then this this
guy that comes up to her and was
basically like um oh is this guy
bothering you that was Peter Kurten the
first guy was also obviously gonna do
something bad because he was trying to
like lead her away to some [ __ ] this
is why you can't [ __ ] trust anybody
I'm telling you like trying to lead her
away into some [ __ ] abandoned park or
some [ __ ] and she was like yeah I don't
like that so then this other guy comes
up hey can I help you and that was a
serial killer so special so yeah he
comes up and he's like okay well
is this guy bothering you and she was
like yeah he is totally bothering
bothering me so that first guy like
walked off right so Peter Kurten says
hey why don't you come to my house and
have a meal and drink I know you're
hungry and everything and then she was
kind of like well she wanted something
to eat but she knew that he was probably
like wanting something she's like look
dude I'm not having sex with you she
basically said like straight to his face
and he was like that's totally fine just
come on I'll show you where there's like
a hotel where you can stay at so he
starts like leading her somewhere like I
said she's just arrived in town she's
not like firm around here so she doesn't
really know her way around he surfs like
leading her into these [ __ ] woods or
some [ __ ] and then he [ __ ] grabs her
by the throat and tries to strangle her
and rapes her so she starts screaming
and eventually like fights him off and
gets away from him now
she told him like specifically like she
[ __ ] ran off and she had told him
that she didn't remember because he like
kind of took her to where she where he
lived right and like shower where she
went where he lived and she said that
she didn't remember where that was which
was a lie which good for her
um now she did not report the assault to
police however what she did do was she
wrote a letter to a friend of hers and
was like wasn't this fucked-up [ __ ] that
happened to me right now amazingly she
wrote the letter to her friend but she
put the wrong address on it so when it
got to the post office like the clerk at
the post office was like this isn't the
right address like I wonder where this
is supposed to be and he so he opened it
so like so he can read it and try to
figure out where it was supposed to go
and he read it he was like holy [ __ ] and
he gave it to the cops
so the the cops read the letter and they
go and find the find her and they're
like okay um do you remember where this
miscreant lives and she says yes indeed
I do and she took them right to peter
curtains [ __ ] boarding house so they
go there it's like Peter Kurten I guess
he comes there and he sees her and he
sees the
at the house and he's like oh [ __ ] I'm
busted so then like he tried to like you
know scoot out the back or whatever
because they'd go to the like the
landlady and they're like hey who is
this [ __ ] that lives in this
apartment and she says oh it's Peter
Kurten she knew exactly who he was now
apparently Peter Kurten was very
surprised that his last victim Maria but
like like lied and said that she didn't
remember where his address was even
though she remembered where it was which
I thought was very funny it was kind of
like BTK like right amazing that the
cops would lie to him oh she's just a
woman she's too dumb to like remember
where I live and just like she
remembered exactly where I lived
BTK was a [ __ ] sucker so yeah so so
he got out but like eventually what he
did okay so what Peter Kurten does is
that he knows now he's like okay well
they know my name they know where I live
they know everything so I'm probably
gonna get busted so he goes back to his
house and he tells his wife Augusta he's
like okay well the cops are after me I
mean she was like his he had been in
prison like in and out his whole entire
life she had been in prison like she
knew the deal I guess so he says to her
all he says to her at first is that um
yeah I raped this girl Maria but like he
admitted that and he said um I had all
these prior convictions so I'm gonna get
caught and if I get caught I'll probably
get 15 years hard labor you know or I
might get put away forever so what you
should do is you should turn me in
because if you turn me in then you'll
get the reward bunny and you'll be set
up for the rest of your life that's what
that's what he said right um so he was
trying to like I said I don't think he
loved his wife in the sense that a
normal person loves a person but he did
say that he was very fond of her and he
did say that he wanted her to be okay
like for the rest of her life
like that she would have enough money to
live because she was apparently upset I
think what ended up happening was that
she was going to like when he came back
and said hey I did this bad thing I
think she was going to kill herself not
because she was like oh I love you so
much and blah blah blah but she's like
well you've essentially ruined my whole
life I'm going to be destitute now
because you're going to prison so I
don't really have any reason for living
anymore and he didn't want her to do
that that's the same thinking BTK had
yeah I mean he was loyal to his family
yeah no you [ __ ] him over yeah which
is totally [ __ ] weird it's weird that
they can separate those two things but
like I said BTK had it word for it he
called it cubing yeah it goes into a
different box right he thought he was a
family man great family man yeah an
upstanding pillar of society even though
you've ruined your whole entire family's
look like it that he didn't make that
connection which just [ __ ] kills me
yeah pillar of society up standing and
doing the Lord's work go to church oh
this other thing I do on the side that's
not really me it's just part of me
that's the x-factor you know yeah don't
worry about yeah that was that's another
me like he didn't think that that would
bleed oh yeah yeah that's a separate
thing yeah
that's why if it this whole thing where
they can compartmentalize in that way
and like put things in different boxes
I'm like yeah that's not how life works
yeah life is not in one box and it
doesn't like something works it works
for them because yeah it's easy for them
to do [ __ ] up they can switch from one
thing to another but it doesn't really
seem to occur to them but it real life
is not like that like just [ __ ] bleeds
into each other they rationalize though
yeah you can't like do that kind of [ __ ]
and expect it it's not gonna have any
kind of lasting impression like lasting
effects like on your family I mean
obviously so yes so the same thing seems
to have applied here so like I said
initially he just confessed it's one
rape and he's like so I want you to get
the money so turn me in so she actually
ended up contacting the police the next
day and she said that even though he
came back later and said okay I'm
pair of jazel dwarf-like he eventually
did confess it to her she said she
didn't know anything about that and
honestly she probably didn't I mean she
knew that he [ __ ] around on her she
knew that he was probably like a [ __ ]
person she didn't know what the vampire
but I don't think well I don't think she
she knew that he was the vampire I mean
obviously she knew that that [ __ ] was
going on because everybody knew that
[ __ ] cuz it was like a big deal but I
don't think she knew that it was him I
don't think she put the two things
together so um so yes she basically went
to the cops and they had planned it all
out and she said he said that he's gonna
meet me at this church or whatever and
so she went there to meet him in like
the the cops are there and they took him
into custody so as soon as they took him
into custody he pretty much like
confessed to all the crimes including
some that they didn't even know about
that had been accidents or had been
discovered he actually ended up
admitting to sixty eight crimes
including ten murders and 31 attempted
murders and like I said he didn't really
try to excuse them exactly but he did
say that it was basically as revenge
because you know his childhood was
shitty like all the time that he spent
in prison was shooting like everyone had
been shitty to him in his whole entire
life so he was basically it was
retribution is how he kind of saw it I
don't bite I don't either
um and honestly most of the even the
psychiatrists at the time were like
maybe that was 10% of it but 90% of it
was lust sexual was a sexual proclivity
that's what he was doing he was getting
off on it that's what he told for it
that was the excuse he gave to
investigators but I'm just I'm just not
think I'm not feeling that that's what
the motive was yeah no he had a perverse
sexuality using well yeah and like I
said even psychiatrists at the time says
that they said yeah maybe retribution
was like a tiny percentage of you but
almost all of it was because he just got
off on it he was a sadistic sexual
psychopath I think you explained it I
think it's the same thing as BTK
yeah different manifestation but like a
BTK yeah and he did later admit to and
like I said this kind of plays into the
whole vampire thing that Maria Han was
another one that he had like drunk so
much he said that he drunk so much blood
from her neck that he threw up like he
just drank so much that was coming out
he also said that he had cut the head
off a swan and drank all the blood that
was like shooting out of the neck like
after I cut it off and like he really
got off on that and it's activated of
course he's always [ __ ] ejaculating
so he's a Coober so like I said after he
got arrested and he was um you know
found guilty within like a couple of
hours of of all the murders and he was
undergoing interviews by dr. Karl Berg
who would later come out with the with
the book the set at the sadist and he's
basically like he basically admitted
that sexual pleasure was his main focus
was his main motive and he said pretty
much the only way that I can achieve
sexual excitement is by seeing blood or
engaging in violent acts either like
thinking about it or actually doing it
and that he was like really into like
you know just being alone in thinking
about all this kind of stuff so despite
all this I I do feel like curtain as
they usually do like his defense team
was like well I think his initial plea
was he was going to plead not guilty by
reason of insanity um but because the
psychiatrist was like yeah he's [ __ ]
up but he totally knew what he was doing
he's completely sane so they let him
stand trial for murder in April of 1931
he got charged with nine counts of
murder and seven of attempted murder
um so his plea was not guilty by reason
of insanity but yeah yeah while he was
at the trial I love this they kept him
in a cage it was like it was just like
his head was sticking out the side and
then like the cage and then like he had
his legs like chained to the ground
because he was like well that's not too
crazy because he did kind of go
rampaging around the [ __ ] streets
stab and bring the people so
like that Russian serial killer they did
that Chikatilo yeah then they put him in
a [ __ ] glass box for sure yeah
they've done that they do that a couple
times they've done that in Italy and
like a few other ones they just like
when they don't even want to [ __ ]
they'll like just get in the box
[ __ ] yeah we don't even want you
running around so yeah so they put him
in some [ __ ] cage umm but yet he says
all kind of [ __ ] like and there's some
[ __ ] quotes that he said like while
he was even on the stand he was like
talking to the judge and stuff like that
he says talking about his arson he says
when my desire for injuring people awoke
the love of setting fire to things awoke
as well the sight of the flames excited
me but above all it was the excitement
of the attempts to extinguish extinguish
the fire and the agitation of those who
saw their property being destroyed now
the judge asked him at some point like
if he had any conscience or remorse or
any pity or anything like that and Peter
Kurten said and I quote I have none
never have I felt any misgiving in my
soul never did I think to myself that
what I did was bad even though human
society condemns it my blood and the
blood of my victims must be on the heads
of my torturers though the events I have
suffered have destroyed all my feelings
as a human being
that was why I had no pity for my
victims yeah that's what he said okay so
he said that at first he had pleaded
guilty just so his wife could get the
reward money for turning him in and then
he said like a few days into the trial
he said like no I'm not guilty like when
he first like entered the plebes like no
I'm not guilty reason if insanity and
they were like yeah no you're not going
you're not fun for not falling for that
then a couple days into the trial he's
like okay no I want to change my plate
back to guilty again could have been
that he realized it going to an insane
asylum would be worse than going would
be worse and I kind of had a little bit
of a death wish as I will get into a
little bit because one of his best
quotes was one of the [ __ ] they asked
him like before they [ __ ] executed
him but um so he said to the court and
this is also a direct quote he said I
have no remorse as to
the recollection of my deeds makes me
feel ashamed I will tell you that
thinking back to all the details is not
at all unpleasant I rather enjoy it
and they asked him about his wife also
and he said why don't you understand
that I am fond of my wife and that I am
still fond of her I've done many wrongs
have been unfaithful over and over again
my wife has never done any wrong even
when she heard of the many prison
sentences I've served she said I won't
let you down
otherwise you'll be lost altogether I
wanted to fix for my wife a carefree old
age which okay I guess that was nice
that's it that's like the only good
thing he did yeah so trial only ended up
lasting 10 days so the jury deliberated
for less than two hours then came back
and gave him the verdict guilty and
sentenced to death on nine counts of
murder also found guilty of seven counts
of attempted murder and Peter Kurten
really didn't seem to give that much of
a [ __ ] about it they said he just just
kind of liked it
that's how it goes um yes Ron yeah he
didn't appeal it um he did apparently
submit a petition for pardon to the
Minister of Justice like that would have
worked whoo and actually the Minister of
Justice was against capital punishment
but even then the Minister of Justice
was like no it's like I'm against
capital punishment in theory but your
urine exception so the pardon wasn't for
release it was for the death sentence
yeah yeah so um but you know at the end
all he asked for he's like you know can
I write letters to my confessor my wife
everything like that so they let him do
that
he had his last meal on July 1st 1931
which was in case you're interested
Wienerschnitzel fried potatoes and a
bottle of white wine okay um he ate the
whole thing and asked for seconds
because it's like hey you're not gonna
get another chance 6 o'clock a.m. on the
morning of July 2nd they took him to the
guillotine because that's what they did
back then 31 you can hear that [ __ ]
was a beheading is always like scared to
[ __ ] I don't think it kills you
instantly I think and that's like yeah
that's if he gets like to the [ __ ]
guillotine they they're gonna put his
head in there he turns to the
psychiatrist I'm assuming it's dr. Berg
and he asks him I'm quoting tell me
after my head is chopped off will I
still be able to hear at least for a
moment the sound of my own blood gushing
from the stump of my neck and the doctor
says yeah you'll probably be able to
hear that for a few seconds and he and
Peter Kurten says that would be the
pleasure to end all pleasure oh here is
blood coming from his [ __ ] neck
stomping dusarque or i guess if you want
to come to me he was metal after all he
earned venom well he was into it and so
they asked him they put his head in the
[ __ ] guillotine and they said do you
have any last words and he smiled and
said no yeah and they cut his [ __ ]
head off now after they cut his head off
as they used to do back then but they
took his brain and wanted to see what
the [ __ ] is the matter with this [ __ ] no
uh no obvious abnormalities in the brain
did they reach down in the bucket and
look at the heads and call his name see
if the eyes open
oh I don't think they did you would
think that they would want to do that
like especially in his case after that
after he said that [ __ ] up [ __ ] I'd
want to pick his ass up by the hair
anything like hey Pete you still do that
during the reign of terror they did yeah
[ __ ] people like their faces see that
that's what ever since you know what I
think you know what I think like really
scarred me for life about that was the
omen like the painted glass like the
another David Warner like you know I saw
that when I was like 5 or 6 years old
and that [ __ ] traumatize me for life
so I've been like I'm like really like
kind of quoted like sort of half
fascinated half horrified by beheadings
and so when I heard about that maybe
when they cut your head off like for a
second
you can still kind of you kind of know
what's going on and like for a second
you might be aware that like hey my
head's not attached to my body anymore
and it's like that is really one of the
most horrifying things I can think of
but apparently Peter Kurten was really
like got an erection at that idea
I guess now seems like now science says
that when your head is cut off the head
part experiences a massive loss of blood
pressure it would yeah but it might
switch second
well they say science says that massive
loss of blood pressure equates to all
near-instant
but yeah unconsciousness but I know from
experience that what science says
doesn't always directly relate to
personal experience there's a chance
that you might be aware of what happened
after this I mean it would be a very
very brief time be brief but all this
smack in the face and the eyes open up
the mouth move it and be like hey yeah
chances are oh [ __ ] that's what I mean
it's like oh I really do oh that's why I
always thought that like I know they
thought the guillotine was like supposed
to be more more humane I guess be like a
more humane execution I'm like is it I'd
argue that it's more humane than burning
people alive sure but it's still not
really hope that you know I mean
especially if you know that it's like oh
[ __ ] my head's not attached to my body
or that even it's only for a second or
say oh yeah the most humane is what we
do here in the United States lethal
injection yeah okay I feel like you just
gonna sleep right it's not painful the
first thing to hit you with is a bunch
of like sodium pentathol yeah and I've
had that for you know for surgery it
hits you and you just home yeah and then
I was you go into lala land
then after that they use put a bunch of
poisons into you you can't recover from
that's what I mean to me that seems if
you're gonna do it that just seems like
the only way to do it just seems like
you know the last thing you think I
would be like
so good yeah yeah the gas chambers not
that good because those dudes [ __ ]
fight it and hold their breath oh that's
what I mean and electric chair is not
good either because sometimes that
[ __ ] goes awry I've seen that really
yeah electric chair would be about
lookout cuz I've been electrocuted
before too that would be like getting
hit with a baseball bat and I've seen
like I said and I've seen ones where
they messed it up yeah and it didn't
like kill the person right away and it
took a few fries yeah what I mean and
they'd be like oh yeah that's smoke in
there yeah and though sometimes their
head will catch by with their hair will
catch fire and stuff it's like no thank
you
so like I said so after they cut his
head off
they took his brain and tried to see
like if there was anything [ __ ]
broken in there and there wasn't now
interestingly they also mummified his
head now it went missing for a little
while but later it turned up and you can
still go and see it as far as I know
nowadays in the [ __ ] Ripley's Believe
It or Not museum in the Wisconsin Dells
I don't know how it ended up there but
that's where it is and I even found like
pictures of his [ __ ] head and it's
got like pictures things it's [ __ ]
gross looking and it's like bisected I'm
not really sure why they bisected the
head I guess because they were just
trying to pop the brain out and they're
like a it's like spatchcocking a chicken
we're just like taking [ __ ] brain out
please easy it's possible I don't
[ __ ] know but yeah so as I said
earlier the film M if you haven't seen
it by a jerk by Fritz Lang is partially
based on this dude's are in Peter Lorre
also based on a couple of the other
serial killers that run around that time
like a you know vampire pan over Fritz
Harmon and all those kind of things
about a child killer so yeah check that
[ __ ] out there was also a movie that
came out and I think it was a French
movie that came out in 1965 called the
vampire do so Dusseldorf
that was also about him and then there
was a another one that came out in 2009
actually which I haven't seen and it's
called a normal and I think it's Easter
European film err so they liked that but
this was about him as well so yeah check
that out like surprised that I'm
surprised that this guy isn't like
better-known I had heard of him but he's
not like one of the big ones that when
you ask the average person about
like the best and zero killers he's not
one of the ones he's not where the names
that comes up you know what I mean yeah
and I just wonder why that is because he
did like some really really [ __ ] up
[ __ ] like drinking blood and like just
stabbed and ran to people and [ __ ]
little kids and men and women and just
everybody it was still a good show
you think I still think it was a good
show how drunk are you [ __ ] drunk
you always think it's a good [ __ ] well
I'm still somewhat sober because I only
had one drink and I drink it very slowly
because I was like trying to get through
my notes even though I lost my place a
whole bunch times but I'm gonna edit
this well I kept going through it I'm
just like I don't need that all right so
are you done you want to shut it down I
quit this [ __ ] you quit the sex with
this [ __ ] okay okay all right so
hopefully you guys have enjoyed episode
197 about serial killer Peter Kurten and
remember if you like the show please
like share subscribe on all your social
media it really does help us out a lot
if you would like to financially support
the show get our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
which goes right to little ol me and
will be used for various upgrades for
the show and paying bills and various
other things if you would like to even
one-time donation also much appreciated
we got good plans for the show we do
we're gonna keep going keep expanding
and keep you and all kind of [ __ ] 200th
one it's coming up soon we will probably
do some live streaming right around them
we haven't figured out exactly what
we're gonna do but we'll figure out
something out so until next time
[Music]
you
[Music]